-Our first guest tonight is an
Emmy-winning writer as well as
an Emmy- and
Golden Globe-nominated actor
you know from shows like
"Mr. Show" and "Breaking Bad,"
as well as the film "Nobody."
His memoir, "Comedy Comedy
Comedy Drama" is out now,
and he stars in the sixth
and final season of
"Better Call Saul," which airs
Mondays on AMC and AMC+.
Let's take a look.
-Here at Saul Goodman
and Associates,
we welcome all ages, all creeds,
all stripes.
-And who is this Saul Goodman?
You?
-You got it.
What Colonel Sanders
is to chicken,
Saul Goodman is to the law.
-Please welcome back to the show
Bob Odenkirk, everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back, Bob!
We've got a lot to talk about.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-Are you kidding me?
What's going on?
What is going on?
Alright.
-This is --
-But wait, wait.
If you're watching this show,
are you watching
"Better Call Saul," too?
-Oh, 'cause --
Well, no, this is on after.
-Oh, okay.
-Yeah.
So you're safe. Don't worry.
-We're all safe.
-There's no -- There's no show
of "Saul's" quality
that would ever air
this late at night.
[ Laughter ]
Congratulations, by the way.
-Thank you.
-You got a star.
-I got a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at this.
All these -- All these people
have killed each other
or might kill each other
on television.
-It's a real reminder
that TV is not real.
-It was so much fun,
and we're such good friends.
-There's your beautiful wife.
And I'm assuming that's
your dog as well.
-My wife, Naomi.
And that's Winnie, our dog,
who we adopted during COVID.
-Oh, wow.
-And now lives next door,
so she comes over all the time.
-That's great.
-We're her grandparents.
-Was this the first time
this adopted dog realized
what a star you were?
Is that why you brought it?
-No, I lectured her every day
from the time we got her.
-Yeah.
-That was really fun,
and Hollywood never feels like
a small town so much as those
Hollywood Walk of Fame
ceremonies.
It is darling.
-It's true.
I don't think people quite --
I mean, it's not like
some massive si--
-Well, you have people from
the Chamber of Commerce,
and they're really proud,
and there's a feeling of
like, "And we have someone here
who made -- He's in TV."
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, I know!
We're in Hollywood." What?
They're so happy and proud
for you, and it's amazing.
-That's really great.
-You'd be very happy.
-I obviously,
like a lot of people,
knew you first as a comedian.
Now, it should be noted,
I also knew you as somebody
who approached comedy with
the same rigor and took it
as seriously as anybody
who does dramatic acting.
-Yes.
-But drama did occur to you
in your early days of comedy
that you might do it.
-Yeah. I mean, it was kind of
a brain-fart moment.
I was on stage with Chris Farley
and Jill Talley at Second City,
and we were improvising a scene,
and Chris was always so funny.
And I'm in the middle of
this scene, but you know
what it's like when you do
the Second City show
and you do seven shows a week
and you can think about,
like, groceries.
[ Sighs ]
"I got to get eggs later,"
and then you're your character
and then you're like,
"Ah, I've also got to get, you
know, some new socks tomorrow."
Anyway, Chris -- You can think
about a million things,
and Chris and I are acting and I
think, "I should be in a drama."
[ Laughter ]
"That's what I should do."
And I really had
that crazy thought.
I was just -- I think I was just
loving his presence so much
and he was so wonderful,
and I thought,
"I can't compete with that."
-Yes.
-But put me in a drama,
and I'll be so funny.
-I worked with a lot of people
where I thought that as well.
-Well, there's a lot of people
who are so undeniable, you know,
that we all know, you know --
Jack Black, Chris Farley,
people I've worked with.
I think David Cross
is always funny.
And so, you know, I had that
thought, but I never pursued it
because I already started my
life as a comedy writer
and I wasn't going to go back in
time and take some,
what, acting classes.
[ Laughter ]
Who needs that?
-But this was the situation with
"Saul."
You know, they called up, right?
Vince knew your work
as a comedian.
-Yeah, it's so weird
because I was writing
and I got a phone call
during "Breaking Bad."
They asked me, "If you want to
play this sleazy lawyer,"
and I said,
"Well, I can do that."
But I'd never seen
"Breaking Bad"
and I didn't watch
"Breaking Bad."
I went and flew to Albuquerque
to be on it.
I watched like 10 minutes of it.
"It's a drama. Okay, cool."
[ Laughter ]
And all I'd seen
are the billboards.
All I knew was guy in the desert
in underwear.
[ Laughter ]
So I get there and -- And I have
to dial it in like that.
But I have me and Cranston.
I'm working with Cranston, and
so I immediately just honed in
on his --
He was gravity, you know?
He was powerful in that role
and every role he does,
and he just brought me into
the orbit of that show.
And from that point on, I --
it was great fun.
And then "Saul" was
a whole nother level.
-Did you pretend that
you had seen the show?
-I pretended that I was talented
and I pretended that
I belonged there and I am
continuing to pretend that.
And they gave me a star
because of it.
-Yeah.
I mean, it must have been --
I mean, we talked about it
because, you know,
I had reached out to you during
"Better Call Saul" -- I'm sorry,
excuse me -- during "Breaking
Bad" about how great you were.
-You have been so kind.
Let's hear it for this guy.
-Oh, no. He's the best.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He -- Listen.
He has been so nice to me and
so appreciative of our show.
And you, of course, you know,
350 people make that show.
And they devote themselves
to it.
And so thank you
on behalf of all of us.
-Well, let me just say, like,
there's never -- there are very
few shows where I feel like you
see the work of 350 people.
And this is a perfectly
constructed show.
It is so well-written,
it is so well-acted,
and it looks really beautiful.
Yet with that said, you must
have had hesitation or thought,
"Is this --?" Because "Breaking
Bad" had this wonderful ending.
It seemed like it was
completely, the loop was closed.
And they were like,
"We're going to spin off."
-I should have had hesitation.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But I got something wrong
with me.
-Yeah.
-I'm missing a part of my brain,
the part that says,
"Hold up, slow down."
[ Laughter ]
"Wait a second.
What are we going to do?"
-Well, we're all the better
that you lack
that part of your brain.
I have a few more questions
about where that lack of --
that part of your brain lacking
has come in handy.
We'll be right back with more
from Bob Odenkirk, everybody.